the olympic i don't watch the olympics i
don't i've never really cared for the
olympics and i
haven't watched it in years but i did
see this clip
this clip that the olympic ceremony
opened with that anthem of
the brilliant genius global citizens of
the world
that awful twaddle by john lennon one of
the worst songs ever written
imagine
join us
[Music]
and the world will live
[Music]
well i did not expect to see the voices
keith urban
here is part of the opening ceremony but
that was spectacular
i did not expect to hear that song that
they play every year since uh
you know 50 years ago and that the aged
boomer hippies
think he's the most important hymn in
the liturgical
calendar and and in our hymnal i did
expect it because they do it all the
time
it's awful it the vision of society that
it presents is just communism
imagine there's no god imagine there's
no heaven imagine there's nothing to
live for
imagine there's no distinctions between
people or anything that makes you
special
it's awful it's a ugly hideous inhuman
vision of society and that's the vision
the ruling elite
wants to push on you i love that the
olympics
opened with imagine i love it in part
because i don't watch the olympics so i
didn't have to endure that awful song by
john lennon
but i love it because it's an
acknowledgement that
the liberal ruling class the sort of
globalized
citizen of the world class doesn't have
any new ideas they've been playing the
same damn song
forever and i loved at the end of this
of the broadcast the
the broadcaster said wow i did not
expect that
that's not a knife this isn't i don't
know my australian's not very good
and so the broadcaster said that
just a little trip back through memory
lane they play this song almost every
year
here we go london 2012.
wow so inspiring
imagine there's no heaven
pyeongchang 2018. imagine there's no
heaven imagine you turn to worm food
when you die
torino 2006.
above us just this physical world and
we're all going to just turn to
take a dirt nap when we die 96 in
atlanta
there wow inspiring imagine
imagine all the people living for their
own hedonistic pleasure
with nothing that is permanent wow
i was reading chesterton last night gk
chesterton the great
great british catholic writer and he
pointed out that the carpe diem religion
seize the day live for today the carpe
diem religion
is not the religion of happy people it's
the religion of very
unhappy people and we all know this in
our own
life we know that that friend of yours
who all he's ever doing is chasing
momentary pleasure
no regrets you regret the things you
don't do or whatever
that guy is never your happiest friend
paradoxically strangely
counter-intuitively according to
many people it tends to be
the well-grounded moderate
religious people who have a family who
practice the virtues
who reign in their own passions they
tend to be happier
isn't that weird isn't that strange
thing it's counterintuitive but it's not
of course
the carpe diem religion the seize the
day we're only living for today there's
no heaven there's nothing above us
we're just just this world that religion
which is the
dominant view of the liberal ruling
class
is a desperate religion just try
it's the same problem that i don't know
if you've ever experienced this but on a
holiday very often tensions are very
high when you're going over your family
for a holiday
or valentine's day is a lot like this
where
you're so focused on having a good time
you're so
intent you think the day will be ruined
if you don't have a good time that you
never have a good time
if you focus like that if you just take
the day as it will
if you take life as it will if you
recognize that life involves a great
deal of suffering
and but there is a point to it and that
actually
there there is an enobling aspect of
this suffering and there's something
beyond just this physical world if you
recognize that
then it sanctifies everything it makes
it much more
comfortable much more bearable uh but if
all you're focused on is pleasuring
yourself all the time
you are going to be miserable i know it
seems counterintuitive
people are waking up to that i think a
lot of the revolt against our ruling
elite
is recognizing that the things that
they've promised us have not panned out
we were told women were told
that if they just stopped raising
families and went out to work for
some old guy at the widget factory 100
hours a week that would make them
happier and it hasn't
the measures of this it's hard to
measure happiness but
such as they are these measures have
shown that that isn't true women's
happiness is declined dramatically
if we just tell our kids
to you know pursue their own ambitions
and interests and our own ambitions and
interests and without
regard to a classical serious education
they'll be happier they're not they're
more stressed they're more anxious and
suicidal than ever
if we just let the liberal ruling elite
ship our jobs overseas yeah we'll lose
our job at the factory but it's okay
because gdp will increase and we'll have
more gizmos from china
and that'll make us all happier will it
no we've got debts of despair going
through the roof we're actually seeing a
reduction in american life expectancy
we've got an opioid crisis running amok
well if we just
empower international organizations and
empower china
then the world is going to live in peace
is it i don't know we just had a global
pandemic allegedly
that you know the worst deadliest
pandemic ever but regardless of the
of the lethality of the virus we shut
down the whole world how'd that work out
didn't work out very well at all and i
think people are waking up to this and
they're saying
oh god they've these people have ruined
my country
the religion of imagine the religion of
imagine that nothing matters other than
our own pleasure and bumping up gdp
and suppressing the idiot percentage and
just following
this ruling class wherever they want to
lead us that hasn't panned out very well
and so i think the trump vote was in
many ways a reaction against that
and i think you're only seeing that
increase the candidacies right now of jd
vance and blake masters the two senate
candidates
who are who are really contradicting a
lot of conservative orthodoxy
who are saying hey we need to forget
about gdp for a second we need to focus
on families
we need to focus on building up our
society we need to cut it out with all
this insane free
quote unquote free trade that's really
primarily benefiting other countries we
need to stop that
that is part of the reaction against
this
no surprise that the olympics is really
you know now the total expression of the
ruling global elite
is collapsing in the rating 16.7 million
americans tuned in to nbc's broadcast
this is the smallest television audience
in the past 33 years it was predicted
that the ratings could drop as low as 17
million people in america and it dropped
even lower than that this is according
to preliminary data
from nbc universal now part of this
is that people don't watch tv as much
anymore certainly that's part of it
people are unplugging their tvs
they don't have cable although it's
worth pointing out this isn't this is a
network tv
so many many more people will have
network than would have cable
but sure part of it is the technological
issue
part of it is just this
vision of society is
is collapsing under under its own weight
steep steep drop the tokyo audience
declined 37
from 2016. 20 37
rather hey hold up there you idiots
i know you're you're idiots according to
the liberal establishment you're
obviously much more intelligent than
they are it goes without saying
but you know what would make you an
idiot if you didn't subscribe and like
and ring the bell uh there's a whole
episode here you can go check that out
called the idiot percentage you get it
at the michael knowles show on apple
podcast spotify google play all of these
other things
and uh i hope to see you next time
especially if you've read my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
we can bask in our own deplorable
irredeemable bitter
clinging bible-thumping idiocy together
see you next time
[Music]
you